let's jump into the first story the
tragic news
from the daily mail have they no shame
woke liberals writing for the new york
times new york magazine and the atlantic
waste no time attacking the colonizer
queen mere hours after her death age 96
and hours after twitter took down
vilepost mocking monarch now i don't
know if i i don't know why that tweet
got removed we should probably look into
it before i make my opinion but i don't
think you should be censored for having
bad opinions i'm glad we get to see
these people being awful because i i
don't i don't want to you know
mistakenly
work with associate with people who
would do something like this
so they write the death of the of queen
elizabeth has been celebrated by some
opinion writers with one promising to
dance on her grave and another
describing her 70 year reign as
devastating while millions around the
world were mourning the death of the 96
year old provocateurs were within hours
of her death mocking the outpouring of
grief in some of the most esteemed
publications in the united states one
pennsylvania professor even said she
hoped the queen's final hours of pain
would be excruciating yeah i don't think
that was the case you're an awful person
jeff bezos was among those condemning
her now deleted tweet good i'm glad to
see it and uh it's nasty stuff man
it's tough
i think what we're seeing here is that
these people will say anything for woke
points
and so
they know they're gonna be contrarian
they know shot content is gonna get them
attention and here they are now getting
it so i won't get into you know their
names or whatever but just point out
like
there are people in this world and in
this country that are just
evil despicable they revel in suffering
and pain there's a lot to say about the
monarchy we're starting to debate you
know the issues of monarchy whether or
not there is one after this because i
know you know what i'm saying king
charles i know he's he's assuming
but is he really
i mean he's already very old
but uh i don't know what do you guys
think about the woke stuff let's get
into that first
yeah well it's not really surprising i
feel like every time a politician or a
person dies that people on the left have
deemed an oppressor whether it's true
direct oppression or not
they think that they are more virtuous
by kind of celebrating that person's
death i don't think that they just think
that it's not bad to do it i think they
actually think that is moral and good
because to them they see themselves as
kind of
you know
on the right side of history and someone
like queen elizabeth as a white
colonizer and oppressor and therefore
why wouldn't you celebrate her death in
the same way that she would celebrate
hitler's death of course i don't think
that's comparable at all i don't think
that she can be compared to hitler or
any other true oppressor in any way but
it's not surprising it's what they
always do so they did to john mccain's
wish they did too
george bush that's what they did to
barbara bush i mean it it doesn't matter
that's what they're gonna do i think the
queen is particularly vulnerable to this
because americans have no comparable
figure to the monarchy yeah um i'm trump
that's complicated but uh you know i
everyone in our office is tired of me
saying this but i'm british i'm a
british citizen and an american citizen
and it is
the
true divide between what i feel like is
my like
upbringing in america and my british
heritage which is that the monarchy is
an institution that represents not only
political power but a cultural history
that is so interwoven with things that
are challenging for the british people
as well as things that are make them
unique and prosperous and i think
queen elizabeth in so many ways
partially because her tenure was so long
she reigned for 70 years there's really
no one like her and during her time you
have to remember all of the social
cultural and technological chains that
swept through england there's really no
one like her and i know you know when
did the reign of the british monarchy
end there's a lot of points in history
where people will say like well this is
really effective and this is really
effective and to me and to a lot of
people that i know
this is the end of the british monarchy
because she represents a tie to a
history that is so far gone from the
culture we have today see harry is it
harry that left with meghan markle is
that harry he was basically done with
monarchy you know at some point it
becomes a burden she became uh in line
for the throne when her
uncle
uh resigned and he said i don't want to
be king i'd rather marry this american
and at the time he couldn't marry her
and also be king so he renounces the
title her father became the king and
then she became the heir to the throne i
mean
monarchy has always been to a certain
degree optional you don't have to take
over the role there's i think british
culture you see it a lot in the
obituaries that are coming out right now
for queen elizabeth which is that she
had a very strong sense of duty and the
idea of a sense of duty at least in the
way i was raised and the ties that i saw
to my british heritage was like this is
a big theme the idea that you rise to
your purpose and you rise through it and
you serve you know and i think in a lot
of ways though there are things wrong
with the monarchy and i think it's
important to be able to criticize your
government
queen elizabeth really represented that
to people and even though there are
people who don't support the monarchy
they don't love it they will still mourn
this loss because it is the end to an
era of british history and british
culture yeah the british empire she
technically she was the empress um until
about what this says 97 when when what
is it hong kong was seated over to china
again
uh that was when the british empire
ended so that's when she no longer was
the empress of course you can be a king
and an emperor at the same time the king
of england the empire of britain and
she's still the effective head of
government in canada i mean she doesn't
really do anything she was still the
effective head of government i think in
australia again those countries operate
independently but she has such a serious
cultural influence that i really think
you know there are lots of wonderful
things about america but that aspect we
don't have and we chose not to we
separated from england for a reason and
i think those things are good but
it's really difficult for americans to
understand because we view our political
leaders with a level of vitriol and we
know they are temporary we know if we
fight hard enough we can push them out
and that's just not how
you know this works i mean she's a
unifying figure even for people on the
left and the right in britain it seems
like a lot of people unified them yeah
or unified around her yeah and i think
part of it is you know
yesterday she met with liz trust who's
the new prime minister she to the end
was conducting business and is such an
integral part of culture in culture and
uh the administrative state of britain
you know we really just don't have
anything like that do you think that
because the the royal family
what was that sorry nothing do you think
that because they know they're like
they're in for life they try to do a
better job of being unifying as opposed
to the politicians here no they're going
to be hated so they're like i'm out
screw you well i think that's part of
their nature that they're not supposed
to be political she really didn't
comment on politics and really none of
them do except for meghan markle because
she's not interested in that royal title
of being a unifier at all yeah i'm not a
fan no no of marvel of markle or royalty
oh okay yeah i mean royalty has its
problems yeah but um you know i can look
i don't i'm not british i'm not from the
united kingdom so if people there really
love her i'm kind of like you know i
don't know what you're thinking we don't
have a queen we got rid of that royalty
i think it's horrific it's it's if
you're born into a family you get to run
the country makes no sense it's the
opposite of meritocracy it has no no
basis in a functional reality or a
system of merit of human merit i but
that being said the first thing i
thought when the queen died was
i i was thought of her family and how
they're emotional how they're handling
it right now
then the second thing was
when you asked me when i everyone looked
at me when i walked in and was like so
what do you think about the queen
and i was like i you know i'd rather
that the monarchy ended and that she
lived than that she died and there's
still a monarchy i have no problems with
her she actually seemed like a pretty
cool person from a distance from the
western media that i was getting my
whole life seemed like one of the best
you know monarchs in human history
personally you know she was very open
well loved and remember she served with
15 prime ministers and 14 american
presidents so
and as far as i know no one doesn't like
her think about everything that you've
seen as a 96 year old think about
everything you can remember when she was
coordinated her the first prime minister
she worked with was winston churchill
which is just like to put that in
perspective who was born
in like 1847 maybe like i can't remember
she was like old when i was born i was
thinking about that there are british
people there are generations of rich
people where she has always been the
queen like she's not just on your money
she is always around well and i think
because the world is so chaotic and
because things in the world and
especially in the uk have changed so
much her steady presence has really kind
of helped keep people sane and now that
she's gone what's gonna happen you don't
know king charles what's king what's the
king gonna do
the king he's what's a king gonna do are
they like are they gonna put him on all
the money now they gotta they gotta he
gets some money and some stamps are
there like other kings on their money
too or is it all queen elizabeth prime
minister um i if i remember incorrectly
different just like we do like with
coins in the dollar and whatever else
like we have different presidents on our
on our uh currency she's on some money
and she's on the stamp but
not all like canadian money too yeah
because she is the head of i mean those
were part of the british empire so she
is still the
yeah to the story so ian was saying
she's the she's the empress and now the
emperor emperor is now reigning supreme
emperor charles is is back
technically the british empire's kind of
amorphous they never really said when it
ended everyone's just kind of like yeah
it just kind of ended when when hong
kong was in 97 they thought maybe the
suit loss of the suez canal was really
when the british empire
no longer had power maybe it's just
exists you know du jour but not de facto
just like she is the figurative head of
government of canada or of like the
british virgin islands right like those
places all have their own governments
and elect their own officials and have
their own form of government it's kind
of in name only that they're still tied
to the empire the empire is not
functional as it once i wonder how long
the monarchy will last at this point now
because the way harry was just like no
man i'm done what i think is that it'll
end up going bankrupt i think that the
monarchy will always be sort of part of
it because you also have to remember we
think of it as like oh it's the queen
and the prince and she's got those
grandkids but like actually there are
still
dukes and duchesses and people like
there are all kinds of titles in british
columbia
like what would the dissolution of the
monarchy actually look like if it went
bankrupt what would happen
well
my thought is
it's very hard to
remove the monarchy entirely because
they would have to undo how they conduct
some governmental business right yeah
and so to a certain extent
there
will be enough people who don't
like who's this it's like
it's king charles now then it's william
and then it's george george so that
gives us like what at least a hundred
years probably more yeah i think part of
it is that they will become less
influential and it becomes unlikely like
i wonder if they'll have to hold some
other kind of office their government
will evolve well it's not just enough to
be granted this power you have to have
something else i think you know charles
got to bring it back to their roots
start issuing letters of mark sending
out naval destroyers
private vessels to raid cargo ships
i think that would be fascinating bring
back colonization there we go but where
would he colonize that's well china's
colonized mars that's right i mean the
next 21st century colonization would you
be psyched about the monarchy if
tomorrow king charles is like i'm
sending something to them hell no it's
got to be done in a decentralized urban
way where we're all in it together
because if we start what's going to
happen is corporations
it's going to be corporations starting
to colonize it yeah that's going to be
true yeah talk about a monarchy the
owner of the corporation while while
they're actively criticizing
colonization and they're like these
people china's actively colonizing
they're literally called
it is literal colonization africa south
america yep and even australia and
america and europe yeah it's it's you
know because their idea of colonization
is like they think white people are evil
yeah so they assume a bunch of white
people get on a boat and they all have
like devil horns and pitchforks like
yeah we're gonna go kill the ground
people yeah but in reality it was like
people saying there's not a lot of land
here anymore i'm going to get in the
boat and go find a better place to live
they don't yeah
so what's happening now with
colonization in china is that it's just
regular chinese citizens being like i'm
going to move to the united states and
go live in new york i'm going to move to
vancouver and then what happens is large
swathes of these populations move into
these areas they create you know little
uh cultural centers little chinatowns
and things like that and that is literal
colonization well it's a lot more
nefarious than not in places like africa
and south america the chinese government
is going in there and saying oh you want
a railway great you get to you know pay
us this amount of money ethiopia can't
pay them back for it oh you're in debt
to us now we own you
so it's not as much like creating
chinatown as hey we're gonna literally
take over your country yes by putting
you in debt but i i just wanted to
differentiate between the evil vision of
colonization that they these these woke
leftists think versus
when you just have a large population
moving around and moving into places
yeah you're right they also have the
belt road initiative they're doing a
bunch of these these these deals like
you mentioned they are actively doing
oil exploration in africa and south
america they wanted to they wanted to
dig a nicaraguan canal yeah to compete
with panama they're are expanding
rapidly not to mention the south china
sea so you want to talk about modern
colonization maybe we can get some of
our friends over the woke left to
criticize it but somehow i just don't
think they're going to do it they
usually criticize the
israeli colonization of the west bank
there's
when you talk about colonizing it could
be barren land people go and create a
colony there of people that's a form of
it but then there's also where you go
and seize someone's property and then
you set up your house there which is
also a form of colonization but they're
completely different really ethically
one of them you're not displacing humans
the other one is you're seizing people's
land so in in israel for instance
there's a lot and i get a lot of the
media through the western media so it's
hard to parse what's happening but i've
seen videos of people getting off of
buses like israelis with or or americans
that have been invited there to colonize
the west bank and they get off the bus
with like mattresses in their arms and
just run and they're all charging racing
to get to the house first where the
palestinian guy is not home and then
they take it they go in and they're like
this is my home now i don't mess with me
the police will will shoot you so you
this is where we took it yeah i'd want
to dig into that i think people have
talked about that and there's something
about that that i don't fully understand
yeah that's intentional and i don't
think just jumping from china to israel
the two biggest colonizers on earth
right now are the israelis and the
chinese that is one hundred percent not
who then who's the other second right
israel is so small how many people live
in israel yeah but
there's there's a billion and a half
people in china talk per capita they're
colonizing the west bank what else are
they colonizing and gaza the west bank
but i'm talking per capita we're talking
we're talking about what percentage of
the population are colonizing right now
israel yeah you're wrong i mean it's
colonizing it's been conan since
thanksgiving
i mean i just don't know i wouldn't be
you know no but arguably
we're talking about one of the most
populous nations on the planet with a
billion and a half people
send having their citizens either freely
move or military expansion onto every
continent on the planet even antarctica
to antarctica to a certain degree it's
just like there's no reason to bring up
israel in that context billion people
the two largest yeah come on no you
can't compare one point three billion to
eight million yeah but you gotta go per
capita i'm not talking about it per
capita per capita it's very much you
have much less probably in china because
there's so many people and so few
relative colonizers i don't know what's
this obsession with israel you're
talking about like a nation obsessed
with israel
like right now you're like
hell bent on are you denying that
they're colonizing the west bank but
what does that have to do with
globalization colonizing wouldn't they
say that that was their land in the
first place that they were the first
people there because they were
historically i'm not i don't even know i
don't know your argument i don't i
haven't seen the video i don't know the
evidence of what you're talking about i
would just be curious because i haven't
really heard about it the argument of
why it starts with what i think
if it's actually happening like where
else are they colonizing you look at
china they're all over the world
colonizing like where's israel going
right a lot of people i think considered
ethical colonization because it's
internal but
you know
the population of new york city is like
what nine million people so it'd be like
are you comparing it to like if the
population of new york spread out across
the country is that colonizing you know
like if if a bunch of new yorkers
started going from manhattan to jersey
city i i went to florida and they were
like fighting and they were like rides
and stuff like it's bad but i just don't
know how you compare the size of
population to what china is doing i mean
it's not like israel is sinking you know
vietnamese shipping vessels firing uh
missiles over neighboring islands into
territorial waters of other countries
whoa whoa hamas and israel have been
firing missiles into each other's
territory for yes you're talking about a
small regional conflict that's a little
sequence yeah it is great compared to
china expanding in the south china sea
no i'm not comparing sending okay so
i guess there's a comparison in that
they're both colonizing different maybe
different you're just saying like
they're the first and the second yeah
the two the two largest colonization
programs on earth right now are in gaza
west bank and the chinese i'm pretty
sure that's just not true and that's a
weird thing to say
i wouldn't call what's happening in
israel like i i would say i feel like it
is yeah russia is probably the second
biggest colonizer and where in what
aspect they're invading right now
there's a military invasion yes and then
also just the expansion of like there's
more russian troops and people spreading
out than israeli
do you have that number somewhere bro
russia russia took crimea and now
they're that's another invasion though
it's different colonization is like not
military i mean i guess there's there's
fight there could be fighting okay i
don't i don't i don't get the point
california is colonizing texas and
arizona and colorado i think new yorkers
are colonizing florida they've got left
during covet and they're like we like it
here we're going to stay and bring
everyone up i mean
it's it's a hard comparison to make i
understand what you're saying that there
is conflict there and it feels like one
force has more power than the other but
i do i wouldn't classify what's going on
in israel as colonization more than
regionals israel was a british and
french colony at the end of world war
one they they promised the allied forces
the british french in um
uh italians promised that area to the
arabs if the arabs would betray the
ottomans so the arabs were like oh
you're going to give us this area that's
now israel you're going to give this to
the arabs would then yeah we'll betray
the ottomans they betrayed the ottomans
the french and english won the war and
then they said you know what arabs we're
going to renege on our offer we're going
to keep the land for ourselves and then
they created the sykes pico agreement
and that basically
set up israel as we know it but it was
very small and then over the next 30 or
40 years i think
there was like a military buildup and
then all of a sudden in the what was it
the 50s i think they had the seven day
war was it 1957 1963 all around that
time
um and uh just conquered a lot of land
around it whether you want to consider
that colonization or not here's the
question is all
colonization wrong do you think
it's a good question you ask not before
the show too
i don't i don't either there's there's
this romantic romanticizing it on the
left about like native americans for
instance
they
just they want to believe this narrative
of the evil white man from europe coming
and just massacring all the natives it's
like oh don't get me wrong there's a
bunch of really bad history there of
course yeah lands get conquered war
breaks out and some people win out over
others but it's like
i don't know man the aztecs were kind of
brutal you know they were warring with
each other they were sacrificing people
ripping out their hearts and stuff like
that so it's hard to say
you know but by based on our standards
as americans with the constitution the
answer is yes
if you think our standards are better
than other country standards so uh you
know hong kong for instance i think you
mentioned this before the show they had
like it seems to be getting really bad
for them now with china moving in
because we don't we don't think china's
values are good values they're
authoritarian they they uh
let's just say the people who are living
there are not doing so well you got the
uh
the uyghur concentration camps so would
hong kong be better off with you know
western colonization i think the people
there their thoughts
yeah i think they would have thought so
i mean they're the ones that are being
thrown in jail for being dissidents and
so i would say that you know they try to
champion free speech which are western
values those are not universal values so
but i don't know that the inns
necessarily justify the means in all of
these cases but was hong kong better off
as a british colony 100
yeah imagine
what this country what the united states
would look like if
no one ever came here
i mean what would it be
i i can't imagine that it would be
substantially well developed well i
think leftists have this fantasy i've
noticed this they've got this like
romantic fantasy in their head
that before civilization things were
better that if we all went back to
living in tribes and just like living
off the earth and that we would be
better off than we were well then we are
now with civilization
it is objectively better to stub your
toe and then die from the infection
right yes that's true antibiotics are
bad yeah exactly western medicine for
the win
pretty brutal they were there was tribal
chieftains ruled by
i think we're insulated from brutality
in a certain extent to because the way
we live now because of modern
conveniences i also think that
you know and i'm grateful for that i
don't want to say that i would prefer to
live in a more brutal time
but i also think that we are used to a
certain level of stability that was just
not true for most of global history i
mean all of the borders of countries
that we see now even if you don't like
that they were part of colonization they
exist because we went through a period
of exploration discovery i mean no one
today is going to get on a boat and be
like i'm going to find some land and see
what happens there like we can't do that
because we know what's out there you'd
be nice but you should go find like an
uninhabited island in middle of nowhere
and be like i'm going to build this up
you know make something out of it i'm
going to turn it into something we can't
do that because it belongs to everyone
now because we've explored the world
like that time period is difficult for
us to relate to which i think helps feed
this narrative that colonization was bad
because we don't really know what life
was like while that was going on here's
here's here's a funny thing there's a
story i've told before about this woke
guy i was talking to north dakota
and uh it was at the dakota access
pipeline protest i said you know i have
to leave by tomorrow because i have a
meeting in los angeles and i got to
drive from north dakota to l.a which is
crazy not a meeting tomorrow but in a
few days so i gotta leave tomorrow and
then uh he was like nah man you
shouldn't do that
meeting schedule that's colonial
thinking and then i was like what what
does that mean he's like it's colonial
thinking man like like having a meeting
and a schedule the native americans
don't have that they like wake up when
they need to and they get to work and
they get it done and then i was like
having a meeting is colonial thinking
like what are you saying like where what
does that mean like that i'm tracking
time it's like yeah like the colonizers
from europe came and they brought these
schedules in time yeah you know these
these meetings and then i was like what
are you talking about dude like asians
had schedule have schedules too they're
not white people yeah in their minds
they think colonization is all modern
success and all modern success is bad
and i'm just like you're a white
supremacist with a guilty conscience yes
they attach everything that they don't
like to colonialism and white supremacy
like the gender binary there was this
like new york times article the other
day saying maternal instinct
is a myth that was created by like
western men in order to oppress women
and i always go back to like whether you
believe the bible is the inspired word
of god or not it is still a book that
was written at least 6 000 years ago by
eastern brown men and like literally one
of the very first verses of the bible
says that god made them male and female
so the gender binary is neither western
nor modern and so it's so funny when
people think that we can just like we
can't see back also isn't this like a
bigoted point of view to take feel like
you know native american people couldn't
schedule or figure out time like that
seems like a horrible stance to be like
only white people know how to like make
appointments what are you talking about
african-american history museum remember
a couple years ago they put out that
like that page on their website that was
like being on time yes and having lists
and having schedules delayed
gratification yeah
i was like dude
asians invented the compass 1 000 years
before your ancestors did so don't come
to me and talk about how the white man
created everything because you just
you're a white supremacist you genuinely
think white people did everything right
get out of here with that stuff it was
it but that's their attitudes they're
like they're on the left and they're the
good people because they recognize that
they are the superior race but they
should be nicer to poor people it's like
get out of here dude
i think that's such a horrible stance
today
that's their stance
i'm like this idea that you so when i
asked about this i when i said asians
have schedules bro he goes yeah but that
came from colonies colonization and i
was like what and he's like like the
white colonists came to china and east
asia and brought that with them and then
i and that's when i was like dude they
invented the compass a thousand years
before europeans did and gunpowder like
pretty sure they were doing their thing
before you got there that's crazy that
he thinks he's the not racist yeah
amazing algebra's uh arab yes yes
it means
yeah it actually means the reunion of
broken parts or bone settings
wow that makes sense that makes sense
it's cool thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you